سالنا الناس مشاهدينا في مصر لو اوتيحت لك
فرصه تاخذ قيلوله في عملك هل تستفيد من
الفرصه ولماذا تعسيله مش قيلوله تعسيله
[موسيقى]
يا اما بشرب فنجان قهوه لا طبعا يا فندم
مش هنام لان الشغل تمام العمل ده عباده
فلازم نعمل تقدير للوقت بتاعنا
واكيد يعني في فترات
فترات ننام فيها بعد ما نخلص الشغل بتاعنا
بتمشي يعني ده اول يوم صعب
يعني حصلت بس يعني لو في تعب تعب قبليها
يعني ضغط فتره كبيره وكده ممكن ارتاح شويه
لازم نتفق القيلوله دي يعني مسموح بها ولا
لا هل دي من من قواعد
العمل ومسموح يعني مثلا يقال ان في
اليابان
يقولوا لهم يوميا من الساعه كذا لكذا
وانتم في المكتب بتاعكم ممكن تاخدوا
قيلوله
انا معظم وقتي شغلي بره يعني 24 ساعه يعني
لو حد كلمني او حاجه وكنت شغال برضو هرجع
لشغل تاني لا ليه دي بتاعتنا احنا هاخدها
اه مش هسترجع يعني هاخدها
وهجرب حظي
ولو ظروفي مع الوقت الوقت اللي انا باخد
عليه فلوس ده في اي حاجه تانيه غير
الوظيفه يعني منيحه الدينيه حرام وفي نفس
الوقت كمان ضمير يعني الانسانيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات